um for you now that uh you're obviously
winning 1.9 million dollars on a random
night at the at the cosmo all right what
are you doing like with your money are
you I mean so I'm about to um I'm about
to really start diving into the real
estate thing nice um it's actually great
time yeah because it's about to crash
yes so just wait like nine to 12 more
months not work work because it's really
the rates are super high yeah and the
price has not corrected yet yeah once it
correct you'll be able to get a lot yeah
yeah that's smart man yeah so I'm about
to start getting real estate and then
it's just a few things I want to do with
my money like um
I got I still got a lot more money
coming in bro like that's the thing like
I got so much [ __ ] that I haven't I
ain't drop no album man I still gotta
get paid for that [ __ ] and then how many
plaques do you have right now
I only got two plaques so that's that's
the thing like when people say like you
ever go on academics and you see the
[ __ ] [ __ ] about people in the
comments like Lucy fell off and or
artists they say artists fell off and or
any other people say that about you yeah
actually I you know what's crazy is that
I feel like I don't pay attention to
that [ __ ] because in my opinion just
based on my Optics I'm like yo you're
like
bigger than ever yeah because when I
talk to people yeah they really [ __ ]
with you like I feel like yeah that's
like see that's the thing about me like
I feel like you're like like not like a
uh I don't know not like me bro it's
crazy I don't do anything yeah I don't I
don't bother any I don't even go out the
house like so like you let the comments
get to you though hell no bro good
because that [ __ ] is like tired like
people if people knew how I was living
like outside of like right well I'm I'm
straight like my life is good I I just
had a son I mean my congratulations I'm
like it's your first baby first baby
how's that changing you man just
a lot of the things that I used to do
and the things that I used to be into I
ain't into no more like I mean just
negative [ __ ] I ain't I don't live for
the negative I live for the positive
that's smart man I feel like once you
can like I mean we've all been young
we've all been [ __ ] through our turn
stage where we take everything personal
where we're always like I feel like once
you get past that [ __ ] it's like when
you really start leveling up your whole
life yeah bro when you stop letting
little [ __ ] dictate how your day goes
yeah bro so like the young [ __ ] bro I'm
kind of past the young [ __ ] like that's
why the [ __ ] like bro even with ddg like
it's like
yeah well there's a couple artists that
like I'd have had that issue with like
when it comes to the girls like and
whatever the issue was like I mean bro
we'll look back at this [ __ ] 20 years
from now and be like damn like for what
yeah what was that [ __ ] about so like
for for the internet and all that [ __ ]
is cool it's good but in reality like
it's too much [ __ ] going on nowhere it's
people and I I'm not fighting no body
you shouldn't we have no reason to fight
it's too many people out here dying 100
right I ain't so I don't like with that
[ __ ]
yeah it's like yo man like this [ __ ]
ain't worth it like like at the end of
the day
I mean like I said when I was like yo
everything I should not real beef though
to me yeah it's not because we don't
seen each other like if we really had a
real problem
no matter where we were you guys are
great guys yeah both you guys are not
like I know I've had artists sit here
that I'm like okay that guy's probably a
bad dude someone I wouldn't want to hang
out with all right yeah I'm not that
though bro yeah I ain't that I'm your
child it's a difference between like
Street [ __ ] and hood [ __ ] I'm just a
[ __ ] from the hood yeah she's a good
dude man get into it